GRANLUND
RETRIEVAL, TIPPED ON BY
TOLVANEN.
SAVEDUP FOR KUNIN.
CHASE IT.
BACK IN THERE, STOPPED BY
IN FRONT, LOOKING FOR A DECEPTI
A -1-1.
A RISING SHOTJOB.
TURN OVER, GRANLUND. AT  OETTIN
GREAT VISION, AWESOME SHOT. RIG
10 SECONDS IN THE PERIOD.
BIG BATTLE.
TOUGH.TIME.
THE PREDS HAVE TO BRING IT  HE
US LATE.
MIRO HEISKANEN WILL BE BACK IN
THE LINEUP ONONTHAT FAR.
>> Willy: QUICK CENTERING PASS.
BEEN. SAROS
A LITTLE TROUBLE BUT NOT MUCH.
>>
TIME AND GET YOUR LINE OUT
THERE.
>> Willy:
GREAT TO THE NET YOU TAKE A QUI
THEM LOOK AT THIS, GOING TO.
>> Chris: THAT IS MUCH HE HIT
THE TRAFFIC IN FRONT., RIGHT TH
HIS TO
READ WHEN IT IS THAT HIGH.
>> WilEND AFTER YOU GET THE
SCORE.
THIS IS A CALM, DRIVING WIDE.
DUCHENE,  HELD O OTHE
SECONDARY SHOTS, BUT LOOK  THE
CARRIER,
BEEN ON THE DEFENSIVE PLAY.
STUNNED. ERE, IT MIGHT BE A
THE PRESSURE ON.
19 SECONDS.